[Music]
hey this is Mel strong and welcome to my
lecture on humidity part 2 if you
haven't watched part 1 I suggest you go
and do that first then this one will
probably make a lot more sense
so to recap from last time we talked
about two methods that we use to
describe humidity one was mixing ratio
and the other was dewpoint now mixing
ratio is probably the one that's the
easiest to visualize and it's describing
how many grams of water vapor are in
each kilogram of air so it has units of
grams per kilogram
dew point it's a little more abstract
but it describes at what temperature the
air would become saturated so if I say
the dew point is 40 degrees one of the
things that that tells you is that if I
cool it down the four degrees tonight I
will get condensation or do so both of
these are used to describe humidity and
what we're going to do is we're going to
talk a little bit about how we might be
able to change those two variables so
let's imagine I add water to the air
somehow so you can imagine maybe I'm
boiling a pot of water and water is
evaporating out of my pot going into the
air then how is that affecting the dew
point in the mixing ratio of the air so
if I can add water to the air any by any
means both the mixing ratio and the dew
point will increase now the converse is
also true if I remove water from the air
both mixing ratio and dew point will
both decrease now key idea here you
cannot change one without changing the
other
so think about mixing ratio if I add
water to the atmosphere I can think of
it like I'm adding grams of water to the
atmosphere mixing ratio must go up but
if I add more water to the atmosphere
that means I don't have to cool it as
much before it becomes saturated so the
dew point also goes up so if one goes up
the other must go up if one goes down
the other must go down it's impossible
to change dewpoint or mixing ratio eat
either way up or down without changing
the other one in the same way so keep
that in mind now we also talked a little
bit about how you might change dew point
last time and same goes for mixing ratio
which is often the a change in wind
direction will result in a change in dew
point or mixing ratio so for New Mexico
where we live if we get a twin coming
say from the north or the Northwest that
wind has come from somewhere cold and
cold air is always dry air so generally
that equates to low dew points low
mixing ratios if we get wind coming from
the south east that usually comes from a
location that's pretty warm and has
pretty high dew points and high mixing
ratios so those values will go up now
this is also true pretty much no matter
where you live in the United States if
you're getting a north wind that wind
probably came from somewhere up in
Canada where it was cold and dry if you
hear the wind coming from the south it
probably came from somewhere more humid
in your mixing ratios and dew points
will increase as a result so what what
I'm going to do is show some practice
problems here and these are all problems
that are kind of revolved around this
concept so we'll go through the
questions and we'll go over the answers
here so here's the first one says the
mixing ratio in this room today is 3
grams per kilogram okay the temperature
in here is 70 degrees Fahrenheit so I go
and I just turn up the thermostat in a
room and then warm up the room to 80
how has the mixing ratio changed so
here's a choices mixing ratio increased
decreased didn't change or not enough
information to answer okay so so all
we've done is we've warmed up the room
okay so when you have a question like
this you ask yourself okay did I add
water to the air or did I subtract water
from the air
now all I've done is raise the
temperature so I did not add any water
to the air I did not subtract any water
from the air so the mixing ratio
is still three grams per kilogram now
the reason I'm giving you this question
is because in the past some students get
confused once we learned how temperature
changes maximum mixing ratio they tend
to one that try to change the mixing
ratio itself with temperature so in
other words a lot of people on this
question would say oh it's warmer
it's a warmer temperature therefore the
mixing ratio went up no not unless we
added water okay so in this case the
mixing ratio has not changed okay let's
look at another one pot of water boiling
on the kitchen stove the windows and
doors are all closed so we are air in
our house is sealed how is the dewpoint
inside the kitchen changing increasing
decreasing not changing not enough
information to answer okay so if I'm
boiling water on the stove then clearly
I am adding water molecules up into the
air as the water is boiling or assuming
the pot is open water molecules are
coming out and going into the air in the
in the kitchen so if we're adding water
to the air in the kitchen that's going
to increase dewpoints and this one the
dew point would be increasing so another
one tonight
dew starts to form on the grass outside
as it does so how is the dew point
changing overnight increasing decreasing
doesn't change not enough information
okay so if do is forming that means we
are we have condensation if we have
condensation that means that we're
taking water molecules and we're
bringing them down and we're putting
them onto the grass onto the ground
somewhere and that is removing water
from the air we have to remove water
from the air to make do okay so if we're
making do we're removing water from the
air and that is decreasing the dew point
okay so we're going to decrease the dew
point as we remove water from the air to
make the dew
which of the following locations most
likely has the highest annual average
dew point and so if you're unfamiliar
with these places you can kind of look
at them on a map but we're last time if
you remember we looked on the internet
at Earth Knoll Schoolnet and we looked
at where most of the water vapor in the
world is and it's along a band kind of
near the equator so if you live
somewhere we're surrounded by warm ocean
and you have warm temperatures you're
gonna have pretty high dew points so of
these choices Miami is probably your
best bet for having highest average dew
point okay dew point in this room was 50
for temperature is 75 I turned the
thermostat up so the room warms to 80
how has a dew point changed okay so once
again you ask yourself did I add water
to the air J subtract water from the air
or did I not add or subtract any water
from the air so all I did here is so we
know the dew points 54 temperatures 75
so if I increase the temperature have I
added water to the air no if I
subtracted water from the air no dew
point still 54 okay so dew point has not
changed okay similar to one that always
seemed just a minute ago a pot of what a
water is boiling on the kitchen stove
windows and doors are all closed how is
the mixing ratio inside the kitchen
changing
so again if you're boiling water on the
stove that water is coming out of the
pot going into the air we're literally
adding grams of water to the air so that
mixing ratio is increasing wind has been
blowing from the west for several days
suddenly shifts directions and starts
blowing from the east how's the dew
point likely change so we just kind of
talked about this so if it's coming from
the West it's coming from off the
Pacific Ocean the Pacific Ocean is very
cold and the dew points are usually
going to be
very low over here coming from the east
if we trace that ear back somewhere it
probably came over maybe the Atlantic or
maybe the Gulf of Mexico and the dew
points were pretty high so most likely
the dew point has increased ok dew point
in this room is fifty four temperature
is 75 I turned the thermostat down so
the room cools to 40 does the air become
saturated in other words another way of
asking this is do we make do in our room
so in order to answer that I need to
know the dew point 54 okay then I need
to know are we cooling it down to or
below the dew point yes
we're cooling it down to 40 that's below
54 so we are going to make do we are
going to saturate the air so yes same
question except I added one more
sentence does the dew point change okay
so to illustrate what happens here let's
consider I got two thermometers one
measures temperature one measures
dewpoint let's say okay so right now the
temperature is above dew point and let's
say I cool down the room all right or
maybe this is happening outside doesn't
matter so I cool it down 10 degrees
temperatures drop 10 degrees dew point
has not changed
why is dew point not changed we haven't
taken any water or added any water from
the atmosphere cool it down further now
it's 60 dew point still hasn't changed
same amount of water in the air now we
drop it down to 50 and at 50 degrees air
is saturated okay so from this point
forward we're gonna start making do so
right at 50 where the temperature equals
the dew point right at this point right
here both of those values are the same
the air is saturated and what we would
get at this
instant in time would be like
microscopic do tiny tiny little
particles you could hardly see but as a
COO it further below 50 those little Dew
droplets we're gonna start to grow
larger and larger now as I start to grow
do larger and larger I have to take
water molecules out of the air and put
them down onto the ground like the grass
or if this is happening inside to beyond
the walls so here we are 50 I'm going to
cool it further down to 40 and notice
what happens dew point has to change
with temperature so if the temperature
drops to 40 the dew point also has to
drop to 40 and if I drop it further to
30 the dew point still has to follow the
temperature and also go down to 30
one of the laws to keep in mind in your
head dew point can never be higher in
temperature ok dew point can never be
higher than temperature so here they're
the same you can have temperature higher
than dew point but you can't have dew
point higher than temperature ok ok
monsoon season in New Mexico and we
notice that over several days the dew
point is decreasing right so let's
imagine worth it's in August and we
notice that the dew point has been
decreasing for several days how will
this most likely affect our weather
so if dew point goes down that means
there was less water molecules in the
air if there's less water molecules in
the air you're gonna have a harder time
making precipitation right so if you
want to make a cumulonimbus a
thunderstorm you need to have water
vapor available for that to happen
so when dew point goes down the chance
of precipitation goes down with it
usually so most likely we would have a
lower chance of precipitation ok story
problem dew point is 52 today does not
change for the
next 24 hours it's sunrise a temperature
of 68 by noon the temperature is 85 by 4
the temperature is 94 when do we have
the highest concentration of water
molecules in the air is that sunrise is
it at noon is it at 4:00 the amount of
water in the air doesn't change not
enough information to determine so what
do you think about that one so the key
to this question is in the first
sentence it says the dew point is 52 and
does not change for the next 24 hours so
the only way I can change dew point is
to add water to the air or subtract
water from the air the fact that the dew
point is not changing it tells me does
not change for 24 hours so the amount of
water in the air is not going to change
for 24 hours so d the amount of water in
the air does not change so you have to
in your mind keep separate temperature
from dew point temperature can
effectuate up and down every day dew
point often remains constant all day
long for day after day after day
sometimes so today we're introducing a
third way to describe humidity which is
relative humidity turns out relative
humidity is the most common way that
humidity is described to the general
public but it's also completely
misunderstood by almost everybody we're
going to talk about why it's so
confusing in a minute but you've
probably heard relative humidity before
in a weather report they might say
something like the relative humidity is
35% okay so before we explain what that
means let's make a point to explain what
it does not mean it does not mean that
the air is 35% water vapor because in
the last lecture one of the things we
talked about is that water vapor ranges
somewhere between zero and almost 4% of
the total of gases in the atmosphere so
there's no way that it could be 35% of
total gases so it does not mean that we
can define relative humidity
as this fraction where we're looking at
the current mixing ratio that's on the
top divided by the maximum possible
mixing ratio at the current temperature
on the in the denominator now for this
class generally speaking you're going to
be given the the top you're going to be
given what the current mixing ratio is
and the bottom number we're going to
have to look up from the table that we
had last time so then we take that
fraction and we multiply it by hundred
to turn it into a percent so relative
humidity is given as a percent between
zero and 100 percent so what does this
tell you well the percentage tells you
how close you are to saturation so 100%
relative humidity means the air is
saturated meaning it can't hold any more
water vapor okay so we're gonna do a
sample problem and here's an example of
the type of problem that we would see so
mixing ratio is 4 grams per kilogram the
temperature is 80 degrees Fahrenheit
what is the relative humidity so the
first thing I do is I write out the
definition of relative humidity it's a
current mixing ratio divided by the
maximum possible possible mixing ratio
at the current temperature times a
hundred okay so what do we know so the
current mixing ratio is given to us
that's 4 grams per kilogram so put that
in on the top now the maximum possible
mixing ratio at the current temperature
the temperature is 80 degrees I've got
to go back to the graph that we used
last time
here is 80 degrees the maximum possible
mixing ratio 20 7.01
grams per kilogram so I'm going to put
that in 20 7.01 Bram's per kilogram
times 100 all right so I'm going to do
that calculation
4/20 7.01 times 100 and I get 14.8% okay
so that's my relative humidity all right
so now what I'm gonna do is I'm going to
change the problem by just changing one
little thing which is let's go back to
the original problem and let's say that
it's 80 degrees in the afternoon when
all this happens and then the Sun Goes
Down and becomes cooler and it cools off
overnight and it cools down to 50
degrees and everything else stays the
same the mixing ratio is still the same
so let's make a new calculation of
relative humidity all right so back to
this what do we know well we know that
the top of the fraction is still the
same but now the bottom of the fraction
has a different number because we're at
the different temperature so I go back
to the table 50 degrees the maximum
possible mixing ratio is 9.2 4 grams per
kilogram so I'm gonna put that in 9.2 4
grams per kilogram times 100 ok so now
we will do that math so I've got 4/9
point 2 4 times 100 is forty three point
three percent okay so here is the point
and this is a really important one where
I'm gonna say this more than once the
relative humidity was about 15 percent
and then it jumps up to 43 so more than
doubles right so if I went to the
average person on the street and I told
them that this morning or this afternoon
the relative humidity was about 15
percent and then tonight it went up it
more than doubled most people would
think that we must have more water in
the air because relative humidity went
up if the relative humidity doubled most
people would think oh we must have
double the amount of water in the air
because that's what humanity describes
except that's not what happened because
the mixing ratio is the same for both of
these the mixing ratio tells us how much
water is in the air there's four grams
for every box you know every one
kilogram box of air so the relative
humidity went up not because there's
more water in the air but just because
it's a cold air temperature this is why
relative humidity is so confusing to
people the general public thinks that
when relative humidity goes up the air
got more humid there's more water in the
air but in fact that's not what happened
at all the amount of water in this case
stayed exactly the same what happened
was we went to a colder temperature and
the colder temperature meant we were
dividing by a smaller number which gave
us a bigger answer so what this really
tells us is that initially we were
pretty far from saturation about 15% we
got closer to the saturation we're still
a long ways away but that's all this
really tells us is that the air became
closer to saturation but the amount of
water in this case stayed exactly the
same in both instances and that is why
relative humidity is so confusing
so with relative humidity a lot of times
we're not so much interested in the
actual numbers as much as we want to
know if relative humidity is going to
increase decrease or stay the same so if
you've got one of those problems first
thing to do is write out the definition
of relative humidity which we said is
the current mixing ratio divided by the
maximum possible mixing ratio at the
current temperature now these problems
that we're going to see we're gonna
we're trying to figure out how relative
humidity is gonna change so we're going
to change the temperature we're gonna
change the mixing ratio so even though
keep in mind that even though I use the
word current in here we're projecting
into the future of some
that's gonna happen so it won't be
current so what you would do is with a
given problem is write this out and
think okay is that is the mixing ratio
gonna increase decrease or stay the same
and then is the maximum possible mixing
ratio on the increase decrease or stay
the same once you figure that out you
can figure out whether the overall
answer the relative humidity itself is
going to increase decrease or stay the
same but you don't actually have to do
any math you're just trying to reason
out which way it's gonna go so I do a
couple of examples here so the mixing
ratio today stays constant throughout
the day how does the relative humidity
this afternoon compared to this morning
so we're going on the assumption here
that this afternoon is warmer than this
morning normal day okay so then we write
out the definition of relative humidity
and think about okay is the numerator
gonna change
is it denominator going to change so
let's start with the top is the mixing
ratio going to change here it says
mixing ratio today stays constant so the
top of this fraction is going to stay
constant throughout the day because
we're told that the bottom though
maximum possible mixing ratio at the
current temperature the temperature
itself is going to change and so we from
the chart we know that if we increase
the temperatures throughout the day the
maximum possible mixing ratios are also
going to increase so that tells us that
the bottom of this fraction is going to
increase as the day gets warmer so that
means we're taking a number even though
we don't know what the number is and
we're dividing it by another number
that's getting bigger if you divide by a
bigger number you get a smaller answer
so from this then we can predict that
the relative humidity is going to
decrease as the day gets warmer we're
dividing by a bigger and bigger number
as the day goes on so do another one
here you put a sealed box of air into
the refrigerator as it cools how does
the relative humidity change so
by sealed box we can assume that there's
no water that goes in or out of the box
there's some amount of water vapor in
the box we don't know how much so we
don't know the current mixing ratio but
the way the problem set up it's not
going to change
well the bottom of this change yes we
are assuming that we've got air that is
probably room temperature we're putting
it in the refrigerator it's going to
start cooling and so again from the
table as we cool down the temperatures
we're going to have smaller and smaller
maximum possible mixing ratios so in
this case the bottom part of this
fraction is becoming smaller so now
you're taking a number you don't know
the number but whatever it is you're
dividing it by a smaller and smaller
number as it gets colder and colder so
what happens to the answer it gets
bigger if you divide by a smaller number
you get a bigger answer so the relative
humidity increases as this box gets
colder let's do another example
so sprinklers come on in our yard in
they stay on for 30 minutes and says
during this time the temperature outside
does not change how does the relative
humidity change so could we change the
top part of this fraction well for
sending streams of water through the air
and tiny droplets there's a very good
chance that a lot of that water at least
a portion of it is going to evaporate
and we're going to add water molecules
to the atmosphere right that's not what
a sprinkler is trying to do sprinklers
trying to sprinkle the grass but it goes
through the air and you're guaranteed to
have some evaporation so if we have
evaporation we're going to increase
think of it as increasing the grams of
water in the air we're increasing the
top part of this fraction what about the
bottom well the bottom depends on the
temperature but the temperature says is
not changing right so the bottom part of
this fraction stays the same
so the top part gets larger the bottom
part stays the same so overall my answer
is going to increase so relative
humidity increases as we
water to the hair okay here's another
example it's a little different so on
Monday the relative humidity is 25% on
Tuesday the relative humidity is 45% on
which day was there more water vapor in
the air
okay so what's clear from this question
is that the relative humidity increases
right so let's think about why that
might have happened could we increase
the relative humidity by increasing the
numerator of this fraction so yes if we
increase the mixing ratio then that
would make the relative humidity go up
so that could be a possibility but we
could also make that number bigger if
we're dividing by a smaller number so if
I decrease this number and how would I
decrease this number I could decrease
this number if I made it colder so one
possibility is I could have made the top
number larger another possibility is I
could make the bottom number smaller
either way could have get could get me
from 25% to 45% the problem is without
enough information I actually don't know
which of those two things happen or
maybe it's a little bit of both so this
is the problem with relative humidity if
I told you the dew point increases you
know the amount of water in the
atmosphere had to increase have I tell
you the mixing ratio increases you know
the amount of water and the atmosphere
had to increase if I tell you the
relative humidity increases without more
information you don't know if I added
more water to the air or if I just made
it colder or a little bit of both so
relative humidity is ambiguous and a lot
of times when we're dealing with
relative humidity we just don't have
enough information to answer questions
like this so few more facts about
relative humidity a few things to keep
in mind when temperature equals dew
point your air is saturated and your
relative humidity
is a hundred percent okay so remember
that one inside a cloud relative
humidity
always a hundred percent or fog fog is a
cloud on the ground you can't have
relative humidity over a hundred percent
okay at least not in this class so if
you're doing the math and you come up
come up with a number over a hundred he
did something wrong all right the
relative humidity usually cycles over 24
hours whereas dewpoint mixing ratio
usually do not okay so let me explain
that one a little bit more so if we
measure temperature every hour
throughout a 24 hour cycle day after day
after day we would notice that the
temperature is cycle right
it gets warms up during the day the
hottest time is usually late afternoon
then it cools down and then the coldest
time in the 24 hour period is usually
right before the Sun rises and then the
cycle continues again right we have this
call sign wave curve of temperature well
what we said now several times is that
relative humidity depends on the
temperature that's on the bottom of that
fraction that we keep talking about so
what that means is where the temperature
is the warmest we would expect the
relative humidity to be the lowest and
where the temperature is the lowest we
would expect relative humidity to be the
highest so this is the kind of graph
that you expect to see with relative
humidity in a normal 24 hour day the dew
point in the mixing ratio don't change
very much in fact usually especially
here in New Mexico day after day after
day you typically have a pretty constant
dew point usually okay but the relative
humidity is always in a 24-hour cycle
because the temperature is in a 24-hour
cycle so we typically see the lowest
relative humidities the hottest part of
the day then they rise at night so we
see the highest relative humidities at
night and then the cycle repeats again
so again I keep repeating myself
but it's really important to emphasize a
lot of people are super confused about
relative humidity if they have a little
weather station they look at it and it's
night and they see the relative humidity
go up they think oh there's there's more
humid there's more water in the air but
no that's not what's happening the only
thing that's happening is a temperature
as increase temperature has decreased in
the night time which makes the relative
humidity increase so with all this
confusion then good question would be
why in the world that were using
relative humidity at all in fact when I
started this I said that we use relative
humidity more than the other two
variables so one of the reasons is that
it's related to human comfort or
discomfort so you've probably
experienced these at some point if you
have a hot day with high relative
humidity you feel miserable and we'll
talk more about this in the next lecture
but a lot of it has to do with the
evaporation or the lack thereof of your
sweat in fact there are something called
the heat index sometimes referred to as
a misery index and on the y-axis here we
have relative humidity so there are 0%
to a hundred percent this is the
temperature from 70 to 110 and these
boxes are what it feels like to you
that's the heat index so you'll notice
that for example if you have low
relative humidity it actually will feel
cooler than it really is
right so if it's a hundred degrees
outside but the relative you made it is
0% then it feels like it's about 91 okay
so that's nice but of course what's not
nice is when you get too high relative
humidity right so if you have a 100
degree day and 80 percent relative
humidity you end up with a heat index of
157 meaning it feels like it's a hundred
fifty seven outside so in New Mexico we
don't really talk about this too much we
don't have much of a heat index here
because a relative humidities are
usually kind of especially in the summer
they're kind of in this range up in here
so we really don't have to worry about
this too much if you live in the
southeast for example they deal with
this a lot now what we do get in New
Mexico a lot is the second one here hot
date and low relative humidity that
produces desiccation meaning that your
skin dries out right so you know when we
have these days especially in New Mexico
they occur usually in June is is the
time where we have the hottest
temperatures and the lowest relative
humidity in your lips are dry and your
skin is dry and your itchy all that
stuff right so that's because a little
relative humidity and then it also
affects the way you feel cold
temperatures as well so when it's cold
and the relatively relative humidity is
high it does feel colder to you another
reason that we use relative humidity is
for fire danger so when you have low
relative humidity that means it's much
easier to start a fire and then once the
fire starts it's much easier for that
fire to keep burning and then finally
it's related to evaporation rate and
we're going to talk about this in the
next lecture but when you have low
relative humidity you have very rapid
evaporation so let's go back this is a
question that they had the beginning of
this lecture temperature in this
classroom of 75 the dew point is 54 I
changed the thermostat and the
temperature rises to 85 degrees as the
room warms up what happens
dew point increases dew point decreases
dew point doesn't change not enough
information well in this case if I just
increase the temperature
I'm not increasing the amount of water
in the air
I'm not decreasing the amount of water
in the air dew point does not change
okay so this is what we're saying in the
beginning of this lecture that when we
increase temperature and we decrease
temperature if we're not adding or
subtracting water
dew points and mixing ratios don't
change
I take this exact same problem and they
just change one thing instead of dew
points I change it to relative humidity
now as I warm the room up the bottom of
the fraction of relative humidity
changes right
so this is a typical problem that you
might face so as I warm the room up I'm
dividing by a number that's getting
bigger
so my overall answer is getting smaller
so in this case the relative humidity
decreases so this is what you got to
keep track of you got to keep track of
dew point mixing ratio and relative
humidity if you add water to the air
what will do each of those do if you
subtract water from the air what do each
of those do if you increase the
temperature what to each of those do
when you lower the temperature what do
each of those do okay
so again if you're one of my students on
learn the next quiz or question is all
about this all right thanks for
listening
you